Imagine you wake up one morning, and you're
under a tree, and you don't recognize anything.
You're surrounded by low, grassy hills. It's raining a bit and smells like waffles and potatoes.
As you rub the sleep from your eyes, you notice a woman, and she's like "Qu'est-ce que tu fais dans la pluie?"
and you're like "What? Where am I? Was that French? Did I fall asleep in my house and wake up in France?"
Then another guy walks up, and he's got a mustache that, frankly, not a lot of other guys could pull off,
and he's like "Wa zijde gij hier nu feitelijk aant doen in die regen?" And that was clearly not French.
And then a little kid comes up with an umbrella,
and says "Wat doe je hier buiten in de regen?"
Okay... Do you know where you are?
Give up? Belgium.
And you know what's an awful lot like unexpectedly
waking up in Belgium with a bunch of people
speaking several different languages you don't
understand? Chemistry.
[Theme Music]
Maybe more than any other scientific discipline,
chemistry has its own language.
Not jargon, though it has that too,
but a whole system of speaking and writing
that's unique to the study of chemicals,
a way of translating symbols and numbers of
chemical formulas into words that can be spoken.
Chemistrian, if you want to call it that (and
I do), can be tough to learn at first,
but it can be done, once you know the rules.
And of course, as with all languages, fluency
really only comes with lots of use,
so I don't expect you to walk out of this
video spouting off about three-keto-two-carboxy-arabinitol,
but I do want to get you off on the right
foot.
So, talking about chemistry can sometimes
be like describing a rainy day in Belgium.
I mean, all three of those people in the beginning
of the video, they were saying the same thing.
They just used different sets of rules to
describe it.
The woman using French, the kid, Dutch, and the guy with the 'stache, a Dutch dialect called Flemish.
So the trick is knowing which rules to apply
where,
and fortunately for Chemistrian, there's a
kind of phrasebook, the Periodic Table.
Just as there are parts of Belgium where different
dialects are spoken,
the rules for describing an element can change
depending on where in the table it is.
This is especially the case with the things that we're going to be talking about today: ions and acids.
These rules apply not only to their formulas, that is, the chemical symbols that we use in equations,
but also to their names, how we write and
say them.
Let's start off with ions.
Atoms become ions by gaining or losing electrons,
giving them a positive or negative charge.
Ions that have lost electrons, and therefore
take on a positive charge, are cations.
Whereas ones that gain electrons to become
negative are anions.
You'll notice, despite the rules of English, that
these are pronounced "cat-ions" and "ann-ions",
not "cayshuns" and "aniuns"
The most basic ions, called monatomic ions,
are formed from single atoms.
To write one as a formula, you just use the
chemical symbol of its base element
and then add the charge as a superscript.
That's it.
If the charge is just of a single electron lost or gained, you don't need to write the one,
but any charge greater than that requires
a number.
So the sodium ion is written like this, while
the ion of chlorine looks like this.
But the names of these ions change somewhat
depending on whether they are cations or anions.
Cations, for some reason, the name is just
the element followed by the word "ion".
So, in this case, it's just a "sodium ion".
But with anions, you use a special suffix,
"ide".
So, the anion of chlorine is chloride, and
is written so.
Now, when we name ionic compounds, we just
say the cation first, and the anion second.
You've done this.
You just maybe didn't know you were doing it.
"Sodium chloride", "hydrogen sulfide", easy peasy.
Now in order to figure out what's what, we have to rely on our handy phrasebook, the Periodic Table.
The first two columns on the left are your
alkali metals, and your alkaline earth metals.
They all form ions readily when they react
with non-metals,
and when they do, they always lose electrons,
forming cations.
On the other side of the table, you'll find most of the common anion-forming elements grouped together,
particularly your halogens, along with oxygen,
sulfur, and nitrogen.
These elements gain electrons to form those
negative ions ending with "ide".
And you've no doubt heard of most of them.
But here's a wrinkle. Many elements can form
more than one kind of ion.
Iron, for example, in the middle there, forms cations, but they can have a charge of either two or three.
This is the case for many of the transition
metals in these middle columns of the table.
They're grouped together precisely they have
these properties in common.
Everything's where it is for a reason people,
that's the beauty of it.
But it's in this middle region of your language map where really unique dialects start to crop up,
changing how ions are named and written.
The formulas for ions here are, thankfully,
as easy as anywhere else,
with the size and polarity of the ion's charge
written as a superscript.
But when naming these ions, we introduce a
whole new naming convention,
and by new, I mean really, really old.
Roman numerals.
Yeah, Roman numerals still have a practical application beyond telling you which Star Wars movie you're watching.
In this case, when saying or writing the name
of a transition metal ion,
you use Roman numerals to denote the size
of the ion's charge, like Iron II or Iron III,
and you write it this way whether the ion's
in a compound or by itself.
Just be sure to put the numerals in parentheses with no space between the cation and the first parenthesis,
because trust me, teachers will mark off for
that.
OK, so I know what you're probably thinking
right now:
Why, in the name of Pliny the Elder, do we have to use Roman numerals like a bunch of Romans?
Well, check it out:
Arabic numerals are already being used to denote how many atoms of an element there are in a molecule,
the molecule's charge, its oxidation state,
the number of molecules reacting in an equation.
We didn't need more Arabic numerals!
So the chemistrians decided to trundle out
the Romans.
Now, acids are ionic compounds just like any
other,
but when they ionize, their hydrogen ions,
just lone protons, become the cation,
and any negatively charged leftover is the
anion.
So all acids are made up of one or more hydrogen
cations bound to an anion.
Writing the formula of an acid is easy if
you know what the anion is.
Because ClO3 is negative one charge, you can tell that it will bond with just one hydrogen ion to form HClO3. Simple.
Now, when we name these acids and anions,
we have to kind of watch our mouths,
because in the realm of chemistria, there's
a whole system of prefixes and suffixes that
you have to keep track of to make sure you're
addressing everyone by the proper title.
Y'know, you don't want to offend anyone.
Once you've acquired an ear for it, though,
you can tell just from the name of an acid
or it's anion what its composition is,
because these prefixes and suffixes practically
give you the formula.
Specifically, they tell you how many oxygen
atoms it has.
That's right, even though an acid is defined
by its ability to give up hydrogen ions,
it is identified by it's oxygen content.
Eh, when in chemistria.
Let's go back to that ClO3 minus. You might
know that as the chlorate ion.
That's chlorate, with an "-ate". Not a number
8. A-T-E.
Like we said, chlorate bonds with a hydrogen ion to form HClO3 which is called chloric acid.
That's chloric with an I-C.
As a rule, all anions that end in "-ate" form
acids that end with "-ic".
Phosphate ion has a three charge, so it bonds
with three hydrogen ions to form phosphoric acid.
Similarly, the sulfate ion needs just two hydrogen ions to form sulfuric acid. You get the idea.
These compounds, the "-ic" acids and their
"-ate" anions, are really common and familiar,
so much so that they form kind of a baseline
for the language of acids.
Chlorine, hydrogen, and oxygen can combine
to make chloric acid,
but they can form way more other similar acids.
And all these variations are named using a
special, super-explicit set of prefixes and suffixes
that tell you whether they have more oxygen atoms or less oxygen atoms than the baseline compounds.
And by how many.
Take HClO2.
Because we know that the cation is H plus,
we can immediately see that the anion is ClO2
minus, which we know as the chlorite ion.
In addition, we can see that HClO2 has one
less oxygen atom than HClO3.
The "-ous" suffix means "less than" and thus
gives us our name, chlorous acid for HClO2.
So the chlorite ion forms chlorous (with an
"-ous") acid.
And indeed, all atoms that end in "-ite" form
acids that end in "-ous". O-U-S.
But what if it has two fewer oxygen atoms
than it's "-ic" counterpart?
For both the acid and its anion, you simply
use the suffixes I just mentioned, "-ous" and "-ite",
but then additionally, you add a prefix.
It's from the Greek for "less than" or "under":
"hypo-".
So, HClO is hypochlorous acid, and likewise,
it's anion, ClO minus, is hypochlorite.
But there are still a couple of scenarios
that we haven't considered yet.
Like, what if an acid has one more oxygen
than the "-ic" version?
In that case, you use a different prefix,
using "per-", Latin for "very" or "thoroughly".
Sounds like it'd be fun to find some uses
for that "per-". Let's do it.
There's perplexed, like very plexed. Pervaded,
thoroughly invaded. Perfect, very... fect.
I had to look it up. It's from the Latin for
"to complete".
So "perfect" is to complete something thoroughly.
I like it.
So the "per-" prefix is just a way of saying
"thoroughly oxygenated", completely, in fact.
If you see the "per-" prefix, that's the highest
number of oxygens that can get on there.
So HClO4 is perchloric acid and it dissociates
into an anion called perchlorate.
And what if, brace yourself, the acid doesn't
contain any oxygen at all?
Remember, hydrogen is the key player in acids, so even though oxygen is common, it's by no means required.
When a hydrogen bonds with chlorine to form an acid, since there's no oxygen it's just called hydrochloric acid,
and it's anion follows the same rules for
anions we talked about at the very beginning,
ending in "-ide", in this case, chloride.
Now, considering what just happened to you
here,
there's a 99% chance that you're now more confused than you would be if you woke up in a drizzly Belgian meadow.
So, if that's the case, get a pencil and get
ready to pause the video.
Now, copy this table down. It's all you need
to know.
Be familiar with the "-ate" ions and the "-ic"
acids
and then simply cobble on the appropriate prefixes and suffixes based on the number of oxygen atoms present.
It might not be as fanciful as waking up in
a Belgian meadow, but it is enlightening.
Just look at all the stuff we learned, like how to determine the formulas and names of mono-atomic ions,
how to find cation and anion forming elements
on the Periodic Table,
how to write the formulas and name transition
metals, and how to name acids and their anions.
Thank you for watching this episode of Crash Course Chemistry, which was written by Blake de Pastino.
The script was edited by me, and our chemistry
consultant was Edi Gonzalez.
This episode was filmed and edited and directed
by Nicholas Jenkins.
Our script supervisor and sound designer was Michael Aranda and our graphics team is Thought Café.